はいこんにちは外れ社長です今回ですね告知でございます何と一緒に僕の事務所の
ブームで握手会します
あああああ俺も随分と偉くなったもんだなぁと思った方
なかなかねえ
そう会う機会も作れないんですよ本当に後悔このようにねやっぱりいつも動画見て
くださる方とさんと面と向かって話せる機会に設けさせていただいて本当にありがとう
ございます
握手会ですよ
建造しません
手を握りつぶしたのでね相手がで詳細を説明しますを11月1日に
全然覚えてねは2014年11月1日土曜日午前12時からスタートしまーす場所は
恵比寿ガーデンホール
東京だなボクも酒造がに住んでるんで東京に行ってやります
立長時間が12時から19時まで会場は11時より空いております詳しくは僕の道あ
説明欄に調査応募フォームが
んで是非応募して僕に会いに来てください
僕以外でをユーチューバーがたくさん来ますヒカキンさん
ずっと大介さん清渓山ササキアサヒさんセット高知産で僕
マスオさんかずさんにヒカキンさんヒカキンさん megumi さんアシア三振立
美香さん love さん
ヒカキンさん豪華なフェチを1500人の中
戦となるので早めに早めかもしれない詳しい事も全部動画の説明欄のリンクから飛んで
見れるので詳しいことはそちらで確認してください大期間は2014年10月7日
火曜日から201210月13決定安倍23時59分までとなっております
僕は生まれ動画で参加できる人東京に来れる人
日にちもしまってこの日に
レルヒというすごい限定して人を集めたところ1500に来ました
サッカーできる東京できてこの日に来れるって人で1500人だからもし僕がね普通に
こうオフ会しまーすと思ったらもう本当に公共の場所とかでは早くか包んで本当に
ありがたいことなんですけど僕出されてこう人前に出る機会っていうのはあんまりない
と思うんでぜひ僕のこのツラをね
5拝みに来てやってください11月1日です
そうするねで僕も本当にいつも見てくださってる皆さんの顔を一度見てみたいに懸命と
思って日々生活してるわけなんだよひ皆さんと握手したいですよ
別にこれで握手しないから把握し変えたませんじゃなあというわけでぜひに11月1日
土曜日
ぜひ会いに来てください see you next バンス
ん